hey guys it's just eat it I'm here with
RO know so this has been out for a
little while this is an American Girl
doll that has an xbox I did not want to
open this with anybody else I do want to
behind myself I wanted to open this with
you because I thought this is gonna be
the coolest thing ever
okay so first if you guys aren't
familiar with American Girl dolls
they had them a long time ago yeah a
long time ago because when I had mine I
think there were only five dolls total
feather when the mini you know but then
they think now they have so many you can
make them look like you and my American
Girl doll her name was Molly actually I
think my sister Molly's don't you guys
may have had yeah she has a lolly
yes she had a little plaid skirt yes yes
it is bringing back memories my sister
had this doll and she would take it
everywhere with her she loved her just
so glad to see that they still have
American Girl dolls and they've grown to
what they are today and this is
extremely exciting this is huge this is
so cool let's open up the doll 400 oh my
gosh look at us we're unboxing basically
like I feel like I'm unboxing a doll
version of myself except I wouldn't be
wearing a skirt
mine is the skirt I'll take the skirt
okay you actually have this Curt that
looks just like this this skirt will
probably fit you oh my gosh I have a
skirt that looks just like this really
do you want to go get it now I would
come so fast at all out of here how let
me show you this okay so real you I'll
be here gosh this was the worst part
when you were a child right what your
freakin toy but it's jammed in here okay
you got to tell me oh my gosh
is is it the same skirt is it similar
and it's the same size I feel like it's
pretty matchy-matchy
oh my favorite skirt ever oh oh look at
those little sneakers that hairnet oh
you cook em they have salons that you
can take them to get their - hair
so they can match you or for their own
self because like they have like really
like it's a Hika Hika bowl of hair so
like they had a special brush that you
were supposed to brush it well so they
take it in and you can refresh their
hair oh we got a little something here
oh woops that way so Xbox actually sent
me this because I was freaking out when
I saw a while ago that they announced
they had an Xbox version of the American
Girl doll like I was all over Twitter
freaking out
that's just oh yeah yeah well hey hello
maybe she's got shorts on underneath you
know like the little shorts no boy under
and boy shortest way this is everything
that I have basically dreamed about
since I was a little girl playing video
games and quiz I'm just gonna haul this
out okay let me see it the American girl
damage hair this is everything that I'm
not get her in there either in there
girls we made it look at this what what
there's an aux cable which means you can
plug in music to the chair I think the
chair plays music it's so cute oh my
gosh oh my gosh it's like my size oh my
gosh no you know where some boy shorts
game and even this is not here just get
it - no way how cute I love tiny things
like you don't like like tiny food
videos and stuff like hey love the
accessories - American dolls because
they all the little accessories are so
cute and tiny oh my gosh here's the Xbox
it has its own console it does and you
can put these little things in and it
acts as a projector so you put the game
in and then you slide this and it
changes my opinions no I can't even make
this up oh gosh woman you batter these
things have changed since my sister had
an American doll a lot of change
problem I don't have a dog I got a
jungle
you got a dongle I think so I'd like to
play to the music the head I'm always
jealous that I'm not a kid growing up
now because I mean I had like a
secondhand teddy ruxpin when we tell you
Mr met his eyes in the Wow yes your mine
wasn't really janky his eye was like
this and then like you'd be like you put
the tape in he was like and then you
hear like the actual like the what it's
supposed to sound when you're under it
so you a lovely bedtime story you don't
know you can see this but do you see it
yeah it's a little projection right here
you don't have to be darker it's just
really light oh my gosh it's like oh
gosh and so right have some honey and
you can switch sings switch like each
little scene cutscenes oh it's so cool
lassic so let's put her in her little
thingy yeah this is probably one of the
coolest things American Girl doll an
Xbox you guys this was this is like a
dream collaboration they always better
at collaborations if you had Rowan
Justine dolls what your accessories be
what you have a little gaming baking
everything
oh my gosh yes I would have every US
banking me the little dog and yours
could have Maddy could come with I'm so
glad we're gonna do this unboxing with
me this is so cool I really love it oh
shoot how do we make the chair do Sally
do that one thing we can plug into an
army it's just what they've always been
called but no one ever called dongles
dongles until Apple called a dongle
because I asked my dad do you have a
dongle and he goes what offended I was
like dad it's like a cord
[Music]
it's not that loud which is probably
doing it intentionally because parents
don't want children playing out of their
gaming chairs very smart this is what I
would do I would put the maximum volume
at Pleasant Oh
oh my gosh I love this so much this is
so cool
well ro thank you so much for doing this
unboxing you for letting me do this with
you this was so much fun and I love
unboxings because of you I did my very
first unboxing with you when you got
those glasses glasses yeah and now I
love that you unbox all over your baking
where stuff now yes so I should have
unbox my new computer that you should
take I just wasn't even thinking I got
it home and I was like I've got to get
this set up and never tell Justine how
old my old computer was but then I did
well this is amazing thank you so much
make sure you go check out Rhodes
channel we've done tons of videos
together teacher subscribe go tell her
hello and let me know what you guys
think of this I think it's amazing I'm
so happy oh I love it it's so great I'll
see you guys the next video
[Music]